hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to Jim
Carrey is going through a lot of ups and
downs in his career as me some big hits
and called favorites while also some big
bobs and forgettable projects but people
forget early on there was a movie many
thought would ruin his career and that
movie kind of strangely enough was Cable
Guy it's amazing the amount of hate this
film got both critics of Jim Carrey and
fans as well saw this as one of his
biggest blunders it's too dark many
people said it's just not the typical
Jim Carrey thing the film didn't even
really bomb but the hatred from it was
so massive that several see it as a
giant failure luckily he may later lier
immediately after and his status was
right back on track but years after its
release I have to ask the question is it
really deserving of so much hate the
film in case you don't know is about a
cable repairman played by Carrie who
befriends a client played by Matthew
Broderick when Carrie gets too clingy
and Broderick tries to break the
friendship off Carrie obsesses over him
and does all the typical stalker tropes
you'd expect him to see driving
Broderick mad at the time people weren't
used to seeing Carrie in such a
villainous role I mean okay you did reel
her but that movie was about as dark as
a Care Bears episode the car ride to
club the car hey this was the first time
we saw him in dark shadows gloomy
backdrops and creepy glowing eyes he was
still goofy with a not surprisingly
over-the-top Lisp but people said they
just found it too jarring for Carrie to
be in this role funny easy how Carrie
would do much darker roles in the future
getting both critical and audience
praise the film was also a hard hit
first director Ben Stiller who just had
to show canceled got panned for doing
the movie and shortly after would get
grilled for directing zulan yeah there
was a time where even this movie was
despised partly because of the
controversy involving erasing the World
Trade Center from the film shortly after
9/11 nowadays though who even remembers
that we just see it now as a funny movie
it even has a sequel coming out
since then though Stiller has happily
gotten some pretty big hits even
directed a film that got an Academy
Award nomination which is why I asked
now if we're more forgiving of strange
humor and dark tones it's a possible
Cable Guy isn't really that bad it just
came out at the wrong time I mean don't
get me wrong I wouldn't be shocked if
you didn't like the film Kerry's voice
can get along knowing not all the jokes
work and it's not exactly a comic
masterpiece but I think there is more to
this movie than people are giving it
credit for first of all it centers
around torturing Matthew Broderick
immediately a grade seven second the
idea of an awkward stalker like this
back then might not have been seen as so
mainstream wasn't a while I come across
a person who said oh yeah
I love that movie I've got a few cleany
people like that but for most they claim
that Carrey was just acting too weird to
even understand what he was doing now
with the internet online stalking and
people getting emotional for even the
tiniest thing look back on this guy
don't you think you might have seen
someone like this before
he's obsessed over TV from the past he
thinks life is one big show he has a
problem with boundaries yeah with the
social media we've all come across this
guy now every day we see arguments and
accusations from people who seem in
their own sheltered world one that's
clearly not a part of reality if you
just replace cable guy with guy who
never leaves the youtube comment section
suddenly this makes a lot more sense
doesn't it
thus you can now see where the humor is
coming from those awkward people online
talk tough behind behind the mother's
skirt of ambiguity here it's funny to
imagine if that one guy didn't just like
weird stuff but was actually desperate
enough to devote his entire life to you
come on you know that one person you
speculated about the one that was just a
little too clean isn't it funny to
imagine they're doing creepy stuff like
letting spiders crawl across their face
infiltrating your family or donning
disguises to follow you you don't think
they really do it the fact that could
actually be nice people but admit it
it's funny to think how far someone
being socially awkward can go it's like
an office space we all know that
uncomfortable stapler guy he's weird but
you try to tell yourself
he's harmless that just makes it even
funnier when he says he's gonna do
something insane like burn down the
building it's one of the movie's most
memorable lines from one of its most
memorable characters the Uncle Creepy
person has also been used for comedy and
pitch-perfect key & peele there's
something about Mary and several others
so yeah it seems more and more were
understanding that these people do exist
to what extent well that's where the
comedy comes in we like to imagine and
push it further and further than what's
probably more realistic but that's what
comedy is all about so now that we have
a better understanding years later not
only how many of these kinds of people
there are but this film's intention to
mockingly poke fun of them is it
possible but it was just misunderstood
I'm not saying you have to like the film
as I said before there's perfectly some
reasons to find a kind of annoying at
times but the arguments given in the
past of it either being too dark or too
weird doesn't seem to hold up any more
we have opened up to the darker stuff
and we have become more aware of strange
clingy people in our everyday lives
knowing this now a lot of this is a lot
funnier than you may remember and
compared to other things today
it's not even really that dark yeah it's
got some heavy shadows and weird shots
but the story itself
is it really that intense when you
compare it to other dark comedies
perhaps much like Zoolander if we're
willing to relax and just accept the
designers of the scenario especially now
understanding the context more there can
be a pretty clever comedy watch it again
this time and don't take it too
seriously the idea is wouldn't it be
funny if the social shutting you knew
could do such over-the-top legs nothing
actually is it's an exaggeration like a
lot of great comedy and it's definitely
worth giving another chance yeah it's
still odd and not every joke gets a
laugh but it deserves to be judged again
with the more updated knowledge of its
subject matter it doesn't say or do
anything shocking it's just a funny film
about extremes and it's hard it's just a
dumb goofy comedy but it's a clever dumb
goofy comedy and one you can probably go
back rewatch and probably say to
yourself hey this isn't too dark for me
I'm on this - you're gonna die remember
so you don't have to